There are two Republican Senate races for
2020 that we've been paying very close attention
to and in both of those races.
Republican incumbents are in bigger and bigger
trouble every single week.
And it is delightful news.
It's there's so much bad news going around
right now, bad economic news, bad health news,
bad news about, you know, the laughable nature
of American leadership.
Global, the globe, the presidency is seen
as a global laughing stock around the world.
This is good news.
I'm talking about Arizona and Maine.
I'll tell you about both of them, starting
with Arizona and Arizona.
Martha McSally is the junior senator.
She has never been elected.
She was appointed to serve out the remainder
of the late Republican Senator John McCain's
seat.
She's horrible.
I mean, truly horrible.
She now wants to be elected for a full term.
She's running against or running against her,
rather, is astronaut Mark Kelly.
Mark Kelly is the brother of astronaut Scott
Kelly.
Scott's been a guest on this program.
Very interesting conversation.
Mark Kelly is also the husband of former Democratic
Congresswoman Gabby Giffords, who was tragically
shot years ago.
You may remember the story.
And Mark Kelly would be a tremendously good
replacement for Martha McSally.
And McSally isn't doing well.
And I take great pleasure in that.
In the latest poll, Mark Kelly is ahead of
Martha McSally by nine points.
This is huge.
It's hugely important for the 20/20 balance
of Senate power, which we've been talking
about, because if Democrats are going to take
over control of the Senate in November and
it's a very uphill battle, winning this seat
back is essentially a necessity.
Then we go to the state of Maine in Maine.
We have our old friend, the perennially disappointed
Republican Senator Susan Collins.
She has a serious opponent.
And that opponent is Democrat Sarah Gideon.
Susan Collins was first elected in 1996.
She's had pretty easy reelections every six
years in 2002 and 2008.
And in 2014.
And she is sort of known for this is not a
great thing to be known for, but she's known
for acting like she might take a stand against
her own party, against the Republican Party.
But then in the end, she always falls in line.
You might remember that she was very disappointed
with Brett Kavanaugh, but then voted to confirm
him to the Supreme Court.
She was very disappointed with Donald.
Trump's actions with Ukraine, but voted to
acquit him in Trump's impeachment trial months
ago, even though it feels like that was years
ago.
So it is very much long overdue for Susan
Collins to go.
Bye-Bye.
Sarah Gideon is trying.
The latest poll is old now.
It's from March, but it has Gideon four points
ahead, very tight.
But heading into her last reelection, Susan
Collins had pretty high approval ratings,
as high as 69 percent in 2014.
Susan Collins latest approval rating is 37
percent.
OK, Susan Collins was reelected in 2014 with
a 69 percent approval rating.
Her approval rating is now 39 percent.
This is very bad news for Susan Collins.
It's very good news for Sarah Gideon.
But both of these races races are going to
be fights, so we can't take anything for granted.
The reason I'm telling you this is not so
we can all sit back and say, hey, we've got
two of these that we're going to take over.
Why I'm telling you this is to get you involved
as you think about phone banking if we remain
stuck at home for the foreseeable future.
These are two great races where you could
get involved.
Now, I know some of you are going to write
to me and you're going to say, David, you
centrists shill.
Neither Sarah Gideon nor Mark Kelly are uber
progressive Bernie Sanders types.
That's true.
But we're talking about removing some really
toxic Republicans here.
We should all be fighting hard for that.
Neither Mark Kelly nor Sara Gideon are as
left as Bernie Sanders, but they are orders
of magnitude better than what we have there
right now.
And it's going to be either McSally or Kelly.
Right.
That's it.
It's either going to be Susan Collins or Sarah
Gideon.
Those are the choices.
And defeating these two would be plus two
for Democrats in the Senate.
We're going to lose Alabama right now.
Former senator and former Attorney General
Jeff Sessions is running against Doug Jones.
Remember, Doug Jones won against in a special
election against a serial accused sex assaulter
predator.
I don't know what word you want to apply to
him.
And now Jeff Sessions wants his seat back.
Jeff Sessions is winning by 13 in the latest
polls.
We will almost certainly lose that seat.
So we need these two just to get plus one
very important.
Consider phone banking there.
We'll talk about other important races upcoming.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
David Pakman.
Let me know how the quarantine is going for
you or if you've unilaterally decided to end
your quarantine.
I would want to hear that as well.
I'm Deep Hackman on Twitter.
Quick break.
Back
after this.